is actually it's the fear of they think
that when wife comes to the house they
will take the son away you don't need to
go talking to your mother about every
little issue you've got with your wife
cuz no matter what that mother is going
to hate your wife then she's going to
think oh she's manipulating my son and
vice versa good I respect and love her
however I need to understand that my
husband LS time with his mom his mom
there's cases where women go into the
household as a wife and they have
already have this mindset that no my
mother is going to be it's a red flag to
see that you're going to take your
mother's side when your wife clearly on
the right side of the de I don't think
there's anything the son can do about it
if it's a Mommy's boy I genuinely
believe that that it's because of the
mother if your mom comes and tells you
or oppresses your wife you respect your
mom but you respect your say Mom no
because Allah tells us in the Quran
speak the truth even if it's against
yourself or k some mothers-in-law really
cause fit now yes because they will
gossip now about the wife yes
other Auntie sisters it's your
responsibility as a man to keep the
woman F beat your mom in check in a
respectful way both of them so as a kid
I'm sure most most Bengali were I was
beat all the time for no reason I'd
smile too much I'd beat me or that stays
with you to an extent and you start
resenting your parents for it when you
commit sins outside my brother or my
sister you will see it in your children
you will see it in your car I'm telling
you bro you will see the consequences of
your sin Ripple effects everywhere I
find it difficult to wrap my head around
why you would be jealous of your son
having a wife I just find it very
strange Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to another episode of
The Bitter trip show um I hope you guys
are well inshallah we've got amazing
guests we've got five sisters aldah and
we've got three brothers here are um
today's topic is very interesting
actually and I think a lot of people
like from my circles Etc when it comes
to um dealing with the Mother-in-law so
a lot of brothers get stuck they're like
listen you know and we know the
mother-in-law and the daughter-in-law
there's disput Etc so the topic at hand
is very simple how to deal with your
mother-in-law and also as a man how does
one juggle because one is the one who
gave birth to you the other one that is
the one that's given birth to your
children so it's a very hard Dynamic and
a lot of people want like you know how
can we go about this how do we deal with
this um so in a nutsh show I don't know
if you guys have any experience like I
don't know if you guys have been married
or not for that matter um you don't need
to go personal but yes how do you guys
for example have you ever experienced
um mother-in-laws being high
expectations of like you know like like
you're a slave like she owns you um you
need to cook you need to clean like
you're like servitude like you're her
slave um is this common do you see this
in specific cultures can we
s yeah I think they want to be
appreciated okay maybe that's who who
wants to be appreciated the
Mother-in-law so she's quite hard on the
woman have you ever witnessed this in
families or Etc I in my in my own family
actually and it's kind of it's kind of
mean to do that to person that's outside
of okay all right and they don't they on
top of that like they don't want to have
that conversation as well and okay yeah
all right sisters any like have you guys
come across this like
um I think um seeing a lot of friends
that have that have been married and
stuff the things that they from what
they t told me um it actually the whole
thought of you know going into another
family being with your mother-in-law it
derives from the fact that sometimes the
mother-in-law is actually it's the fear
of um they think that when the wife
comes in when wife comes to the house
they will take the son away and what
when they say that what they mean is
it's no longer the mother you're giving
you know like asking her son to do
something and now it's like another
person is in the household and she is
his priority as well so I think not be
derise from the thought again of that
the fact that it's just pure fear that
the sun is going to be taken away but it
shouldn't be like that it's cuz she's
built her entire world around her son
and so like to the idea of another woman
uh like like taking her son away it's
it's like it's like an abandonment issue
kind of thing as well I've seen that
like a lot in like like South Asian
Community son and I it does happen in
our culture as well and it doesn't have
to purely mean that you know the
mother-in-law is evil there's cases
where women go into the household as a
wife and they have already have this
mindset that no my motherin-law is going
to be evil like you know she's going to
do this to me she's going to do this to
me but if you go with the mindset and
you don't even know how the how the
woman is how she is or how she might be
the complete opposite of what the
mindset you have and you're going to
that marriage thinking she's going to
treat me like this but it's going to
affect how you function within that
marriage and you going into that house
because of your
mindset so my question to you then would
it be how do you deal with a mother not
like
that I personally wouldn't know but um I
do feel like you have to a man has to
have that balance so again you have to
learn to balance it's like you know they
say you never you should never scold you
should never shout at your wife in front
of your mother and you should never a
shout at your mother in front of your
wife so that's like you know when you
when you find something wrong that say
your wife has done something wrong if
you say it you know to her if you should
say it to her in front of your
mother-in-law she this is again this is
scenarios that we've heard like I don't
know if you've seen But on Twitter there
are crazy like you know but stuff that
people write and all these situations
and it's like you just have to kind of
like find the balance between how to
handle your mom and how to handle your
wife would you move in with your uh uh
like and live with your mother
like after like after you you and your
husband are new basically your you and
your husband are newly
married I personally I would I would
it's quite common in the Asian culture
right South Asian yeah because now you
got two Dynamics number one the first
Dynamic is the mother-in-law and the
daughter-in-law cannot maybe get on for
that matter then men are stuck in the
middle um but then it's when you live
with them and to me that's like the
thing is Dynamics work because bro that
is crazy bro it's disaster it's it's a
man's responsibility at the end of the
day to make sure like the mother-in-law
and the and the wife they've got a good
relationship one thing one thing I'd
advise is if you have any disputes with
your wife or your mother or anything
like that never combine the two you
don't need to go talking to your mother
about every little issue you've got with
your wife cuz no matter what that that
that mother is going to hate your wife
then she's going to think oh she's
manipulating my son and vice versa I've
seen the daughter uh sorry the wife
hating a mother-in-law because of what
the h tolder exactly this this is a
basic principle that I I mentioned in
other episodes as well yeah I have a I
have a very strict me personally I
strictly strictly never ever tell my mom
the disputes I have with my wife my mom
will come and say to me what kind of a
son are you never open up to you and I'm
like Mom this between me and my wife me
and her are going to be okay if I tell
you she did a you're you're going to
remember she's treating my son like this
and it can be something that you're
making up in your head you've made it
bigger than it is so I make it the
principle I never ever tell my mom till
this day bro ever my mom would look at
me she go the Bible like why you not
telling me what happened well I get I
get bit of a my m mom goes H I'm like I
just like little argue with my wife and
i' come to my mom's here and then now my
mom's I'm like oh allow me man I just
and then she's like no please and to me
it's like that principle is very
important because some marriage
counselors say that the biggest reason
why divorces happen because you get in
love with what principal sisters again
you guys are emotional you get your like
family members involved immediately the
topic at hand is not getting in-laws
involved but the mother-in-law and to
now live with them Aki how could you so
how could you live a fight and they
don't hear it I'll um that's the problem
I'll give you a bit of information of
like why South Asians move in but like
their mother-in-laws and stuff I have
you our conclusion like was they're not
obliged to yeah no they don't have
islamically don't have to but a lot of
people do it cuz they're such a
tight-knit community anyway like when I
grew up I live with about three
different families we couldn't afford to
live separately so they've taken that
they've taken that mentality and now
they run with it and that's it's passed
down to the Next Generation how many
Asian boys do you know that saying oh
you need to live with my family my
parents and stuff I'd say it's more
common than it's not even if they can
afford to live out they want their
mother to be close to one that they're
called mommies boys aren't they that's
what it is but for meth
because I'm not encouraging it your like
you know your wife she she she says she
wants something but then your
mother-in-law like she disputes this who
do you listen to so islamically I think
actually I did a bit of research on this
correct me if I'm wrong once you get
married your wife should be the bigger
priority than your mother do you know
what I mean so for me I if I got married
right um I wouldn't mind if my wife
lived with um my parents cuz I know my
parents are going to treat her right I
know what kind of people they're like
but I know some of Bengali parents they
they just don't I know they won't be
able to treat their like daughter-in-law
well do you know what I mean cuz they've
got like a superior mindset someone
coming yeah I would say
um the foundation and the base should be
respect so as a
wife to understand your husband's
mother's position she's his mom she gave
birth to him you respect and love her
for that however islamically she has no
rights over you so just to be able to
understand that you know what this is my
mother-in-law spend even if for examp
I'm going to speak more about the fact
that they don't get on um even if I
wasn't to get on with my mother-in-law I
respect and love her however I need to
understand that my husband needs time
with his mom he his mom at the end of
the day and Jenna lies under the feet of
your mother so even if me and my
mother-in-law weren't to get on
alhamdulillah me and my mother-in-law
are fine but if we weren't to be getting
along I would still respect her for that
and
I I would because at the end of the day
I can only be in control of my actions
and how I act I cannot control the other
person so you have to understand that
everyone is in an IND individual but
100% the the responsibility lies on the
husband to create a strong boundary that
your mom is not to speak to your wife
crazy your mom is not to blur the
Lin she's not supposed I don't really
agree with um living with your your
parents-in-law in in in the first place
but she's not supposed to get involved
into your relationship and there is
lines and boundaries it's your
relationship is your marriage your
contract between you her and Allah not
you her your mom and everyone else
you're not all sleeping in the same bed
and there has he has to have that
backbone and I know that some men are
like Mom people laugh that backbone yeah
but like you're going to lose your wife
and what you going to do stay with your
mom I find the whole like I find the
whole like jealousy the whole jealousy
thing like like the jealousy among like
mothers and sons a bit weird personally
like very
strange um like but when it comes to
like evil mother-in-laws and Mommy's
boys when it comes to Mommy's boy it's
never the son's F it's always the
mothers who entice their son to make
certain decisions it's never the other
way around I've right sometimes it is
but I've always found that it is the
mother's fault when it comes down to to
mly just because like the mom's always
in his business asking him what's going
on I just I I I find it difficult to
wrap my head around why you would be
jealous of your son having a wife I just
find it very strange and weird I think
you know I've seen this somewhere it's
it's it's a it's a really deep rooted
thing a deep rooted psychological thing
where the husband was not as great of a
husband to her so she I guess yeah she
found that in her son and that's why she
gets that deep connection with her son
so anything that comes it threatens her
relationship because you know her
husband wasn't a great you know a great
husband didn't give her the emotional
support or whatever whatever it is that
she needed so that's why she's making
that up with her
son but they don't realize they're doing
that though they don't realize have
daddy issues um because they crave that
um and the thing is I think what I was
going to touch up on I think that's what
it stems from is that the the husband is
not in their life and maybe they've
divorced she feels lonely and there's a
fear as well at the end of the day
because a l woman come to this
realization which are those who initiate
divorce because you need to understand
your kids are going to get married
that's when you're going to realize
you're with your cat or your dog or dogs
Haram but or your or your bag what left
with yeah yeah yeah it depends so the
thing is here is that this is when the
realization hits a lot of woman because
whatever for reason I'm seeing there
might be valed reasons but then what
happens is when the father's at picture
they're lonely now and now the son
getting married is terrifying to them
and especially imagine just imagine for
yourself as well put yourself in their
shoes as well yeah because one day you
guys are going to yeah and this is very
interesting whenever I talk about this
issues like when it is feminism or this
kind of stuff I realized you know what
changed the Dynamics the moment when
these sisters come and talk about now
about you know he should do this did
that I'm like okay just imagine that's
your son they br you know what happens
they hold the like oh yeah I'm going to
have a son one day yeah imagine would
you want um this the wife to do that so
think about you guys are going to be
mother-in-laws one day yeah imagine
being at home alone and your son is
getting married yeah this will point the
perspective that's why I see some of the
sisters are smirking yeah is because now
it's like oh my gosh actually that's
going to be me one day so imagine it's
frightening but at the same time there
should be boundaries I'll come to
later not disagreeing
what so yes I'll get you back yeah
basically the I don't know if you guys
know but the problems of um of the um
work like this so you have Gen X the
Millennials and then gen Z when the Gen
X they don't solve their problems it's
going to cater it's going to go to move
on to the words of the Millennials and
when they don't sort out their problems
so now you have two problems they move
on to the Gen Z Now gen Z now we have
three problems for example just because
yes within the frame of respect hik you
advise your parents yes but just to say
because no matter where the toxic is
coming from from cultural standpoint or
just from purely attachment side it
doesn't mean she has a right to just
walk over all over the sun everyone has
a aair because it's Allah legislated not
man legislated laws that we've been
prescribed upon every human every
position no matter father mother nephew
niece you have your own position you can
only say to a certain extent and the way
you say it and the way you go about and
do it is very different now coming to
the son-in-law coming to the son-in-law
is that he needs to know what he should
and should not do before marriage and to
be honest I'm not going to say he's not
ready for marriage but he's very it's a
it's a red flag it's a red flag to see
that you're going to take your mother's
side when your when your wife is clearly
clearly on the right side of the de
because Allah's plan is higher for us in
every Avenue of Life period there's no
there's no go away about doing it this
way or that
way
right um no it's interesting you you you
mentioned whether the father or the
husband would be absent or not um I
think that actually makes it easier for
the man to become the man of the house
um especially the oldest me personally
as everyone knows I live with my grandma
but yeah because I live with my grandma
I won't move out the older she gets the
more she's going to have to be looked
after so I'm going to stay at mine like
B and then it'll be mine after my my my
wife in the future will move in with me
but the only reason the only reason I'm
able to do that is because my
grandfather is is is dead so I don't
know the lack of fathers you'd
think I guess it's I guess it's e all
like my family's never been like that
and but I know other I just it's it's
it's I just find it strange I keep going
back to that it's weird it's strange but
it's difficult to have an opinion on it
because it's quite it's quite a taboo
thing to have uh because you know
they're not think about their sons in
strange ways like that it's just you you
got something yeah as you said like
there's something like right there but I
don't think I don't think there's
anything the son can do about it if
you're if you if it's a Mommy's boy I
genuinely believe that that it's because
of the mother there's nothing your
husband the you know he at the end of
the day he's still an individual you are
you are still you if you get married you
have to fulfill the rights of your wife
okay let me just change cool that's
that's true let
me somehow backone and stand up for
himself yeah 100% I agree with that he
for himself he does but there it's not
his fault it's not his fault I think
that's that's what I forgot to say it's
not his fault he is the way he is he no
he's still it's still his fault he's a
man he has to take accountability if
you're married and your mother your
mother's deciding how your marriage
works where she lives that's that's
ridiculous you should still change your
mindset you should discover Islam
research it find out why am I like this
why is my mother got such a hold on me I
need to change it CU I'm never going to
have a successful relationship if my
mother dictates everything do you know
what I mean and another thing as well I
want to say for Devil's Advocate I don't
believe in this but like I think Sons
sort of value their mother so much
because of the um Hadith why is it that
heaven lays at your mother's feet so I
think they yeah yeah so I think a
lot is it a we narration but a lot of
boys will use they'll use that as an
excuse not an excuse they'll say you
know this is why we value our mother so
much and sometimes I value the mother
more than the wife cuz they think we're
going to go like you know are gates to
Jenna so your mother is a gate to Jenna
how you treat her and yes you should
respect your mom but then there's
there's a thin line between I get what
you're saying but I do feel like some of
these men and I have examples of this
they really are mommies boys like oh I'm
GNA go to my mom oh my mom oh yeah you
know my mom used to cook this like this
or you know they start bringing examples
of their mom do you want to marry your
comp do you want to marry your mom sorry
and then on top of that you you are now
like just my mom my mom you are
comparing me to your mom and it makes
them seem immature but also I have an
example of um this girl that I know her
mother-in-law would call her and be like
you need to put makeup on you need to
dress up for your husband uh she just
gave birth oh you know you've not really
done your hair oh you've not
really who are you to she FaceTime her
and then see her and be like yeah I see
you you're not really you know you have
to do this when you do you have to put
musk when just overstepping boundaries
and just being all up in my business
when you really don't have business up
in my business and I just think it's
it's like it's weird like you I find it
very weird and when I heard of that I
just thought she touch on that as well
similar situation I know like a lot of
relatives at least five or six that have
gone through divorces because of the
Mother-in-law let me div let me say one
thing by the way they n they will
divorce usually this but let me say one
thing it's it's the husband's duty to
communicate with the daughter what's
expected and what she expects they need
to have a conversation so I had this I'm
not going to say who it was butd like a
let's say family friend she moved in
with her husband right they were in love
whatever right she doesn't wear the
hijab or anything like that I don't know
if she's practicing or not I have no
idea but her mother in-law like demanded
you have to wear the hij job you have to
come down you have to cook and clean and
then she asked her husband like we never
agreed this what's going on like you
never said I was supposed to be a
servant for essentially mother that
thing she it's out her Goodwill yeah she
doesn't need to do that she doesn't need
to she only needs to care about her her
own family not extended family she she's
she we had we've done episode she has no
right to stay with them yeah she episode
islamically she has a right to ask her
own place obvious it's from if she if
she sees that the mother's alone it's
it's her choice that she has Mercy you
know and they talk about it before if
she said if he should be clear and say
look I have a mom got nowhere to go you
would have to live with us try my best
to the Dynamics where you know you're
not in each other's face that much Etc
it is it is hard but you know it's you
know what it's like there's ay in the
Quran which is very interesting Allah
says in the Quran the good deed and the
evil deed not Cann not be equal repel
evil with which with uh with one which
is better um and it says faithful
Believers to oh sorry and then it says
Allah orders the faithful Believers to
be patient at the time of anger and
excuse those who treat them badly listen
carefully it says then verily he between
whom you and there there is animosity
enmity as uh you will become good
friends so this very Allah saying Good
and Evil is not the same repel evil with
which that is good but you might have
animosity for example between the
mother-in-law and the U the
daughter-in-law that you might dislike
each other but Allah puts that uh Mercy
in between you guys you get it so uh the
point is very simple like me from my
personal experience uh when it comes to
this stuff I realize boundaries are very
important so for example um I'll give an
example my mom for example it's a little
bit personal but like I'm comfortable
mentioning it yeah and and I'm doing
this for the sake of Allah so genuinely
I don't want like this these things
break down marriages so the bit of Truth
is about that that to me for example I
can remember once my wife I think she
made R and it took took her whole day
like he was like and she wanted to do it
yeah and actually honest even she didn't
want to do if I ask her she should
probably do it may Allah bless her so
the point is this because some people
like yeah I have to ask yeah blue peel
nonsense but the point is this and red
peel is nonsense also she was cooking so
what happened is she was cuz she's so
why I said to her I said I said I I'll
do the dishes I wanted to because I used
to work in a bali restaurant and I used
to watch the dishes yeah so I don't
really I like cleaning cars and stuff
like it's just a hobby of mine anyways
so I said I'm going to do the dishes now
my mom was like get out the kitchen yeah
she's like get out the kitchen cuz my
mom's very like we've been growing up
that did you get it my mom if she could
she could she spoon feed me to this TB
literally BR where are you like and
that's mother but I had to communicate
to her and I said Mom listen I want to
watch the dishes what you doing now
because the thing is like if if if my
wife understood cuz he's speaking to me
in the language but she might feel a bit
hurtful like you know what's wrong if
he's helping me did you get it now is my
mom coming from an e place no it's
because to her tradition she's seen that
like that so now I had to I was in a
real life situ situation I was like oh
my gosh I need to the balance this you
I'm trying to say so I spoke in my
language and I said mom we'll talk about
it later yeah I said let me just finish
we'll talk about later yeah so I done
the dishes hand like I I helped her with
the dish done dishes Etc but she was
telling me like she my mom was saying go
I'll do it so she wasn't saying let your
wife do it she's saying I'll do it so I
spoke to her later and I said Mom you
need to understand I have a dynamic with
my wife your Dynamic may have been
different my Dynamic is totally
different if you get involved all it's
going to do is going to and I'm happy
where I am don't get involved we don't
do respect I had to like break it down
cuz I don't want to hurt a feeling you
get it so I was in a real life situation
where I had to break that down um and
even if my wife kind of sensed it and
was like what was your mom saying I was
like no I know she was just asking me
about you know I just had to make up
something like yeah in Turkey you know
my something about something else yeah
so I had to mention it and that's when I
realized the Dynamics I need to work
with and that worked with me and I and
my mom sometimes have those Tendencies
again where I'm doing something where
I'm helping helping my wife she just
doesn't want me be like in the kitchen
it's not that she's saying let your wife
do it she's like I'll do it you go sit
down and I'm like Mom no you relax
you've come to our house that's because
of how she was bought up you can't even
blame your mom to an extent you just
need to speak to her exactly
communication is a must and sometimes
like for example I see in families I
speak to Brothers as well they're like
how do I deal with this and I'm like one
brother said to me that it's not that
the Mother-in-law was transgressing but
there was certain things that she was
doing that was a little bit hurtful to
the wife but the wife was patient they
sorry to C you but there's an example of
some mothers-in-law really cause fit now
yes because they will gossip now about
the wife
yes other Auntie sisters feeling weird
and other sisters cousins and other
family members are feeling some type of
way because you know the the mother has
said oh she's dirty or she doesn't do
this oh you know I I saw my son cleaning
the dishes and he was doing this and she
doesn't even do this you know and then
the family are now looking at the wife
sideways and she can't now build a
relationship with other family memb
they're judging her already yeah they
judged her based upon so so that's and
that is really a big so toxic that's one
thing that I I I learned from the
experience as well with Brothers as well
is that very Sly
sorry oh sorry so one thing that me
personally actually is when I spoke to
my wife I mean my mom and I told her I
said mom please I'm just asking with
this stuff please don't please just
don't I noticed in my mom that she was
more careful yeah yeah and I realized my
mom was like okay I'll just leave you
and your wife you guys she went a little
okay whatever like so so I realized my
mom now my mom understood as a son I put
a little boundary in place in the best
possible way with kindness and it worked
now my mom like not that M I don't want
to get into details myom my wife's
relation alhamdulillah yeah I don't want
to get into details yeah but the point
is this yeah it worked Mom would be L
she would come even if she sees it she
doesn't say nothing so as a man you have
to it's your
responsibility as a man to keep the
woman folk beet your mom in check in a
respectful way you get what I'm trying
to say both of them so it's your
responsibility if you don't do that
there has to be accountability I don't
buy this nonsense of mummy boy so I
don't give a damn you're a mummy boy you
can come out of it you know what I'm
trying to say it's this is nonsense of
yeah I I don't care you get it it's your
job if I let my mom I swear to God I
would have been momy's boy today if I
let my mom do I swear my mom would not
let me work I had to come out of that I
went and lived on my own I had to go and
explore life you get what I'm trying to
say so there's no excuse in doing that
so it's it's a duty I've already spoke
to my mother I'm not even married yet
but I spoke to my mother I was just
asking her questions I didn't set
boundaries I just asked her what would
you do if me and my M had like a a
dispute of some sort like would you get
involved she's like no that's only for
you two to discuss if you need my advice
I'll give you apart from that she's not
going to get involved that's the perfect
approach
like the mother's there when you need
advice that's it but touching on the
point of what um the sister said with
toxic like gossiping and stuff like that
it's so prominent in our culture South
Asian culture everyone gossips about
everyone it's crazy like that's what
splits marriages apart like little
gossips are half times they're not even
true the Bengali sisters can probably
like say the same thing Bengali aunties
most times like the wife will come and
tell the husband like look your mom's
like she's playing games yeah she's
playing all these games she's making
lines upon my name upon my name and the
the guy will like the guy would be like
dare you speak about my mom like that
how dare you it's so bad like they
really hold their mom to a really high
standard in a very weird way and then
and then yeah and then if you there's
also that if you're a Mommy's boy it
comes in uh comes hand in hand with like
these guys expecting their wife to be
exactly like their mom exactly which is
almost weird to an extent think why get
because a mom is why you've most likely
been babied and like you've been you've
just like you know sat in your room
while your mom cleaned your clothes and
took after you after you and then they
expect their wives to do the same exact
thing and when the wife doesn't do the
when she doesn't do the same thing
they're like so my mom doesn't do this
yeah so let me ask you guys let me ask
you guys a question not your mom like
yeah yeah let me ask you guys a question
then so let's say um you found someone
yeah get married to him his mom and dad
they're quite ill they need someone to
look after him he's the only son or the
eldest son would you be okay with them
moving in with you or no
sorry but my house is my house I will
come personally to look after your
parents every single day I will come
every day that I'm able I will bring
them shopping I will look after them
help them clean their feet whatever the
hell you want me to do but I'm not
living with them that's fair enough
that's fair enough personally I want to
I have to to live my life
they 60 years of life 70 years of life
and now they want to enforce it that's
unfair as well in Islam we are not
supposed to burden one another and that
would be a burden to me I'm not saying I
wouldn't look after them of course I
want the hasset but we can do that from
separate houses we can live closely
enough and I'll go and look after them
I'm not inclined to live in the
household with them and and become the
slave
EV yes I will help but yeah what about
you guys with them and they not a
slave cuz they don't they don't have
demands they're just like
look I think the thing is a lot of women
want privacy a lot of women will want
their own privacy to walk around without
hijab on for example when their
father-in-law is there or brothers of
the father fine I know but like for
example I've got a little brother right
so if my wife moved in with me she'd
have to she'd have to wear the attire
wouldn't she so that's that that's the
issue so if I get married you know true
you know which which comes to our point
which is interesting is that okay these
are uh mommy boys yeah that you guys are
going to be mommies and you're going to
maybe have boys so we need to come to
how are you guys is it the mommies
because we're talking about the
Mother-in-law but you guys are going to
be mothers as well one day so how would
you guys educate your sons because this
is an issue that you guys are going to
face you know it's going to be you one
day with your daughter-in-law so in that
aspect Dynamics are going to change
you're going to be like oh my gosh I I
was talking about myself all that time
so why would you you guys say about your
imagine if you had Sons how would you
nurture them and teach them the dynamic
to understand when that time comes can
was that s um what I would first and
foremost say
is with children they creatures of
imitation so they don't actually think
for themselves until a certain age so
for me personally the best way to teach
them to be should be a strong man is
through modeling it you need to First
find it in a man and the
man's the man can model that aspect of
it and you as a woman can give like that
emotional support teach him empathy
teach him you know the emo the things
that we that is important the life
skills like cooking and cleaning and
doing the laundry yeah yeah exactly
teach them all of that be
self-sufficient as well or you can you
can say words but they won't really mean
much other than showing it yeah that's
the best way by
example I think um I would teach my son
to you know he needs to have a say in
certain things a lot of parents I see
we're talking about mommy's boys right
one of the reasons why they can't stand
up for themselves in front of their
mother mothers is because they keep it
in themselves they ask it's the fear
right again about it's the fear if you
teach your child your son from you know
when from the age where he's he he has
the ability to understand that he now
has a say in the decisions that he makes
and he has a opinion when he grows up he
will have those boundaries he will be
able to stand up to his mother and say
that you know Mom this is how I want it
this is what I don't want but if he's
not taught from a young age from when he
has the ability that he can have a say
he can have an opinion and he can have a
mindset like if he wants something he
will say it you as a mother need to make
him feel comfortable enough for him to
come and say that to you from a young
age if that doesn't happen and it just
continuously goes on for when he becomes
an adult that's how he's going to be for
the rest of his
life yeah so if you had the son and like
how would you train him because at the
end of day you know you know if you
treat him in a way where you do
everything for him it's going to end up
being that Mom's boy that you want
against you know I would give my uh my
son responsibilities from the
get-go um financial responsibilities in
in the sense that I would give him
pocket money to go uh like let's say we
go like food shopping together you and
I'll give him the money uh you pay for
it it'll give him like a sense of
responsibility um uh doing things around
the house um let's say if he has younger
siblings you know uh making sure they're
okay giving him a sense of
responsibility which is going to make
him feel like a man from the GetGo
because I feel like um for a man what
makes uh what makes a man uh a man is um
having that responsibility and
eventually you start to form your own
opinion your own
identity um uh yeah good that's
interesting because you see what you're
doing here your you're you're nurturing
and this is very important why father
figures are important studies show that
a you know a single father uh does a
better job raising than a single mother
because you need to understand there's
some studies that show this here reison
being is for example when a woman gets
divorced she needs to adapt or or take
on masculine traits providing you get it
if you think about it the opposite
doesn't really happen you don't see a
man who's a single father becoming
feminine so it shows that we need
masculinity to survive so which is very
key so it's very important this is the
reason why we talk about divorce and I
know look it happens we're not trying to
blame people Etc the stigma divorce
happens as normal but trying your best
not to because the detriments the after
effects are quite drastic as well it's
important as a because what that means
is again as a mother you need to take on
these masine um roles to now make him a
man now there's going to be a certain
point because I see a lot of people
where the son's reaching the age of 14
15 there's no more I'm going to he a
grown he's bigger than his mom now it's
that is gone at Ru seen a video i s I
saw I saw you know actually I'll tell
you something very interesting here it's
and this is very fundamental so my wife
um and I'm giving this from personal
experience because W the only reason I'm
doing is because I see for myself it
works I'm just want people to adapt it
is that my wife would call my little
daughter like change and Nappy yeah she
ain't coming for nothing bro the moment
I walk in the room and I just say uh
gentl like lay down I'm telling you she
my wife last week she looked she was
cops she was like because she was she
mouth
Dr of course all praise to Allah and
then she was shocked she's like I've
been fighting here but all I did is look
after and said listen up lay down yeah
bro she was putting her legs in the
nappy bro like you get it like leg in
the nappy yeah and I just said you need
to understand the Dynamics is but also
with me it's you get what I'm trying to
say this is how and this is a daughter
this is my daughter for my son boy yeah
boxing yeah but I'm telling you on a
different level you know why because we
have so much burden on our shoulders the
responsibility is so great if I don't
treat show him the hardship now he's
going the this world is going to destroy
so that's the reason why one of the
things we need to teach our sons I don't
have a son I got three daughters ald
yeah but I will teach my son to be a man
do you get what I'm trying to say if
your mom comes and tells you or
oppresses your wife you respect your mom
but you respect you say Mom no because
Allah tells us in the Quran speak the
truth even if it's against yourself or
kin meaning to to us H is more beloved
than my mom my dad I don't care in a
gentle way you say mom I'm so sorry
you're you're here you're oppressing my
wife you're oppressing my wife and this
is not fair it will put a boundary I'm
telling you once twice third time your
mom's going to say you know what I'm
going to take a step back and as a man
it's your responsibility there is no
excuses of being a mommy's
boy I've gone through this time and time
again at home so I'm really worn out
saying it again but the way I'll bring
out my son will be quite harsh uh no
one's trust me I don't think you're
going to like it I tell you know tell my
wife find a son I boxing I st punching
his ribs slowly no slowly no you have to
bro like slowly slowly it's not about
it's about mental toughness I think
teaching your your son to be mentally
tough true but let me tell you something
let me tell as men as men as men we need
physical pain we we love it it has to be
installed in there we have the we have
the you love it bro try it have a have a
cold freezing shower
bro what
um
um yeah no I think I think the father
figure is so important you
know yeah because the father is the one
that enforces the discipline 100% I mean
even I I have dogs one of them is a god
dog um and it obviously they're not like
children but my nan will try and tell
him what to do and it does just doesn't
work because she's too nice she treats
them like actual human being and it's
too nice I only have to say things once
just one time and they do as they're
told it's exactly the the same with
children as well for me bringing up my
son it will be completely my sense of
disag I know we had a similar
conversation about this we did speak
about this but I think it's just due to
discipline yeah
I I'll be harsh on both my children
because the world is a very difficult
place a harsh and horrible place and
that's the reality of it so I'm not
really going to get into how I this
because God knows I'm this I might not
actually do the things I say now so I
don't want to give
um say the wrong things to people
listening say yeah that's a good idea
when in reality I will do shout man you
get arrested for shouting but yeah no
one of the things one of the punishments
yeah if you do anything wrong if you
swear if you cuss if you don't eat your
dinner I will make you sit against the
wall and you will kneel against the wall
for a full minute and you will do that
every single time you swear and you will
not swear ever again by the time you're
like by the time you're a teenager and
you will learn this I promise you and
this and and you know what my kids you
know you're going to watch this maybe in
like 10 years yeah in you're going to
watch this yeah and just remember when
all them times you spent against the
wall yeah you could have prevented
because you you didn't have to swear but
yeah now seriously 100% 100% I actually
know I actually know people I actually
know do that where did they learn to
swear in the first place that's not me
cuz our children don't be swearing okay
no of course that's interesting well I I
was thinking about electrocuting I'm
joking I'm Jing
okay okay
let's talk about Solutions let's talk
about now Solutions these are a part of
it I think that's what everyone was
talking about maybe the symptoms but the
root is that when you have this toxic
I'm good when you have this like um
toxic type of attachment to your kin
folk or your children or anybody it's
going to ruin you if it's to the extent
I know it's triggering for the for
females who who are thinking of becoming
mothers because his heart coding because
it's like he's my son
he's my son as a father or whatever but
still is that little type of thing
because look sometimes I believe that we
don't fear the day of judgment as we're
supposed to meaning that I can hit my
hand like this this is how the day of
judgment will be like this how how you
see some danger in front of you or maybe
a stabbing is the same way you see the
day of judgment your mother is not going
to be it's not going to have a lawyer
you're not going to be your mom's
lawyer uh your your mom's not going to
act as your lawyer period sorry to say
that but it's the truth
so you having these boundaries which are
understandable meaning that a mother is
supposed to you know nurture her child
for generations to come meaning if this
gen if if her son messes up and to Hon
in terms of punishment I know
punishments can be look sometimes I got
licks a lot I used to run away from my
licks I only got one slap one anything
that used to be in my mom's hand she
could just throw at me you understand
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
work it no
he carries
himself the thing is that no no just
because no just no that's what I'm
saying hitting doesn't always mean it's
going to work what I mean by this if you
think that you're going to hit your
children and they're going to fear Allah
because of that sorry no there's been
plenty of people got licks more than me
I know people I to the extent I never
got bruises where was that people going
beat them more than me they don't fear
Allah they do anything and everything in
the world that comes to them so you
giving your son or daughter licks or
stuff like that it's not going to cut it
what is that you need to you need to see
you to analyze how your child actually
ticks meaning that not every child is
going to tick the same way even within
your household oh well his mother's the
same he all all the kids to no even but
in the same house every child has his
own personality has Allah has created
that person with his own risk and risk
doesn't mean money it means sustenance
it means your friends it means your
parents how they treat you as well so
combating that thing of you know just
because that's my son or that's my
whatever it does not mean you have every
legitimate way of saying this is what
you can say and this is what you can't
say no as a son you're supposed to
analyze that you know I'm getting older
now these are the
realities parents alhamd have good
health and you know they will die just
maybe naturally maybe Allah bless you
and give you a good ending this the
reality where the current situation
where a lot a lot of people with a young
Millennial gen taken care of the parents
and one of the you know to contextualize
but I don't think we contextualize
enough is that the issues is that we
don't um so in terms of late 90s there
was the epidemic of AIDS and stuff like
that and the um had to deal with you
know stuff like that but now I believe
in 2030 I think half of the population
will be suffering from depression that's
a that's a factor that has to be cat for
meaning that a lot of people who are
young can they can they sustain that
long period of time in terms of you know
being that that support for their
parents from if if you can do it from a
place where you know I'll dedicate this
time and dedicate this time then that's
perfect because every every Avenue of
your life has a h and you need to
fulfill that to to your end
that's for me personally if I had a
son um that's not my business that's his
father's business and my business is to
teach him to to push him to be mentally
tough to have discipline to do his bed
in the morning to fast when he gets to a
good age to nurture him but also to know
that I'm his mom I'm not his girlfriend
I'm not his uh I'm not dating him yeah I
I want to be close with my kids I have
two daughters I want them to see me like
I'm their friend so anything they can
tell me you know I want to be that
confident for my children however
there's a boundary so if he was to get
married or and I think it's actually
different
because I'm going to be a mother law to
men you know so it's like I don't know
how that Dynamic is going to be when
when my daughter brings a man home to me
am I going to treat him like my son or
you know like that it's it's a different
cuz we always think of mother-in-laws
with a daughter or a woman but we don't
really think of it from the a
perspective as well so am I going to be
extra grilling to the men that come am I
going to be extra strict like I don't
know how I'm going to be but I know for
a fact that if my daughters were to
bring me a man I would be really looking
out for the man's discipline is he able
to to provide for my daughter I would
want that in place before any man just
takes my daughter just like that you
know but yeah for for my son it would be
it will be a very tough time at home not
tough it will be love he'll be love nurt
child give him Grace but I would want
him to be strong mentally to prepare
because the Chinese at the moment
they're not just sitting there uh just
doing L Dar fairy tales and the Russians
as well they are teaching their sons men
to be men they're also going through the
biggest genocide known to mankind the
Chinese and Russ they can't can't use
them as example I think there's too
strict and they're not strict enough I
think the Chinese are too strict um but
on on your point of U but just in
regards to the difference between China
and the UK we're basically fairies
compared to them you know we're true
zero de kids are coming out as
non-binary at the age of like two three
this and that there's no discipline at
all in in the west yeah but there is
something called too much discipline so
as a kid I'm sure most most Bengali were
I was beat all the time for no reason
yeah I'd smile too much i' beat me do
you know what I mean and I think there
comes to a point where it's like um
alhamd don't like that anymore but um
that stays with you to an extent and you
start resenting your parents for it so
there needs to be some sort of balance
of discipline to be honest I don't think
I'd ever physically hit my child
islamically it's wrong like I know you
can I think you can hit him on the back
or something like that right something
like that but lightly but I I'd
never it hurts me if I hit my child I'd
be I'd be killed you know like hitting
like slpp child and child SCH in SCH in
school it's like
yeah people like used to like kind of it
was like a coping mechanism to laugh
about it like not only laugh about it
but like kind of gloat because it's
obviously you do have the exception but
white people are are rarely beaten by
their by their parents I was only ever
slapped once I've never been in
touch and a lot of them SLA their
children
people fair enough fair enough fair
enough my dad my dad's a bit different
my dad is has given me just to make but
my my while live with my n she never she
only gave me a SL once and that's CU I
wouldn't stop moving in the show and I
had cling pain stop moving she said stop
moving I didn't stop M I kept wriggling
about and she said stop moving I just
went I just went stiff I just went still
and yeah I stop moving and yeah it
worked but it's she was but I just find
it I just find it sad to the point where
if you're being if you're getting for no
reason a time because it wasn't a slap
to hurt me it was a slap to get me
that's the difference like to fix up so
I just think like I don't know I I can't
really remember the reason
physic forb us from um punishing you
know disobedient animals like you know
using physical violence on
uh uh the um disobedient animals let
alone human beings and you know you have
to you have to remember that that we
belong to Allah every time like you know
especially for parents like before you
decide oh I'm going to beat this child
because you know I gave birth to to this
child remember that Allah gave you this
child as an Aman as a you know as a as a
gift and you and you were you've been
placed um as that to take care of them
so how are you abusing your Authority in
that let me let me correlate that back
to Mommy's boys right so let's say a
mother and father they hit their boys
all the time right that boy going to
goow up to fear their parents MH and
he's going to fear them so much that
he's going to listen to everything they
say growing up so there's a correlation
that's why I don't eventually you need
to grow a backbone CU someone's going to
get beat up so many time until you know
they come to a Breaking Point they like
you know what like I'm not that doesn't
always happen it doesn't always happen
let's be honest if you're if you're
hitting your child even if it's a little
slap if you think about it it's
violating the child moment you don't
think it's wrong hitting a child it's
legal in this country it's legal there's
loads of things legal that's horrible no
I know but you're allowed to give your
child a slap I think sometimes it's
necessary and as a mom now I'm telling
you now when you become a parent my I
please I rarely rarely rarely slap my my
child yeah I like communicating with my
child however there's been times where
I've had to give her a little spank
because she was about to cross run into
the road even though we've spoken about
it so sometimes you have to feel it as
well as understanding it cuz you know
there's a dangerous situation here and
the child is not listening sometimes you
can't give them a little slap I'm not
saying beat your child the way I there's
the difference that's the difference but
regardless let's see what Islam says
about this Ali what does Islam say about
hitting your child to be honest I don't
know I don't talk I know the in the face
I know that yeah I don't haven't I don't
know bro I'm not sure not really vers on
this one I don't know anything that says
H I don't know but the point say is that
words yeah tonality
everything my children listen with my T
no you have to but I think I think even
like um there has to be like even though
Allah says in the Quran when it comes to
like dealing with your wife which is the
third things when it comes to like it
depends how it's understood some say
symbolic something it's like a map when
you have discipline in your wife yeah
it's more symbolic it's like that it can
be for example if she's becoming violent
Etc that can restrain her okay because
at the end it's that you cannot cause
bruise pain leave a mark hit the face
yeah so restraining anyone can restrain
the police can restrain so are we saying
that categorically you cannot touch
anybody no anyone anyone would agree
that at one point definitely whoever it
is for that matter it's required
necessity then yeah and you need to
understand all of us exactly and the
thing is how many of us have been
through hard test what Allah tested us
with have we all been through that
everyone must does that mean Allah
okay so therefore that did that make us
a better people did it make us better
people there you go so which shows you
what when we do that it's not that we
dislike our child or we hate them and
we're not talking about beating by the
way I don't know what people are talking
about I'm talking about no bloody is
something completely different we're
talking spanking slapping the bum that
is completely fine I think that is
absolutely necessary sometimes
especially with some
children
absolutely I'm not going to lie like
myom was super like I would be like
throwing up me I'd be throwing up she
wouldn't stop like she would she would
find like every weapon that she can find
to like I got I got like scissors thrown
at me for no reason that's what I'm
saying wife it
Point that's not from the that's not
that's notor can I just say as a as a
parent you need to always exhibit
control and even if that means like when
when disciplining your child when
speaking of your child communicating
your child you you always need to have
control the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said in Anger sit down
as a parent if you feel like you're so
angry in that moment go to another room
sit down for a few seconds did the
prophet ever SP child you come back to
your child any of the the child I'm I'm
just ask I don't any any on that so
therefore why should why should we
practice for me the way I see things um
the boys today in this generation I've
spoken about it previously the reason
why a lot of them are running wild in
the streets is because they've got a
lack of discipline and a lack of slaps
I'll tell you that for free because some
of them are stabbing women children they
have no boundaries and and they are
literally have no morals or respect and
it goes to a lack of the Father Figure
yeah lack of Father Figure and a good
good slap the what's interesting though
you see all those Road men most of them
actually have gone through physical
abuse some of them have gone through
sexual not in today's generation you're
not even allowed to hit your kids like
you're not allowed to be your kids this
is this is why they turn out that way
and this is the reason why because
divorce has a massive impact uh for
example in single mother households and
I'm not blaming the single mothers uh
but it it shows that they are more
likely to end up in prison more likely
to get sexually abused more likely to uh
fall out in in school Etc so the thing
is this is so detrimental and this is
why it shows that masculinity a fatherly
figure is so V
so important that's why we talk about
the break of the familyit but just end
on this not is also one thing that we
never talk about is that your
relationship with Allah anytime you see
a dispute when because these things
affect the man as well when he sees his
wife with his mom Etc also look at
yourself and what sins you're committing
because a salaf used to say that we
would not commit a sin except that we
would see our riding Beast or Beast War
in our wife meaning that how many of us
take account you need to understand
something like Allah says says in the
Quan in the wrong dos will not be
successful you need to understand
something my dear brother and sisters
you are watching this at home your sins
have consequences you're going to see it
the Sala would say they would come home
and they see they wife walking now you
know what they'll say they'll be like I
commited a specific sin here and it is
coming out right in front of me yeah or
in the riding Beast the riding Beast is
not listening to them yeah what sin did
I commit do you see how they connected
their sins to the consequences they suff
going through so sometimes you need to
look and say what sin did I
commit asking Allah to forgive you yeah
and if you have obedience to Allah I
promise you Allah will make sure you
have obedience in your wife or vice
versa in your husband in your
mother-in-law these things have a ripple
effect but what do we do let's go to a
counselor let's do this have you tried
obeying Allah have you tried it have you
tried being looking at your sins you
don't do that and you're like oh my
mother inlaw my wife are not getting on
or this that have you tried this is what
people laugh at this brother okay
brother this is the dean have you tried
have you said oh Allah forgive me for my
sins that every time I go out the house
I check out girls and I'm talking to
girls behind my wife back yeah and then
you want obedience in your wife you will
see it when you commit sins outside my
brother or my sister you will see it in
your children you will see it in your
car I'm telling you bro you will see the
consequences of your sin Ripple effects
everywhere the moment you put Allah
first and the moment you start working
on yourself even the little s you're
like I don't want to wrong myself yeah W
let me tell you something this is the
solution Allah has given his and you can
listen to me and say okay brother Ali
whatever Quran here we go again no
problem have you ever tried it you
haven't I dare you to try and write down
the sins that you commit and ask Allah
for for repentance start working on them
make sure you never miss your Salah make
sure you're giv a then come and talk to
me I'm telling you I know a brother he
says to me bro I swear to God my
marriage would have broken down long
time ago from external factors W there's
Divine there's something in my marriage
keeping us together and you look and
it's this brother's actions what kind of
a person he is but you can get as many
sh you can get the evilest mother-in-law
Allah will your marriage as long as you
have obedience to him and you will see
obedience in the creation and if he show
Disobedience to him you will see it
everywhere and you see it see a lot of
relationships break down yeah when they
the lack of remembrance of Allah you see
it you see things
start going exactly exactly the closer
you get to Allah I'm telling you nobody
does this everybody he doesn't praise
Salah he doesn't do that brother what
kind of blessings you
want what does Allah say in the Quan
don't what does Allah say in the Quran
your life is going to be like Allah says
in the Quran it's your own hands that is
your own hands bro how many people take
to account they don't and you know what
they do I'll tell them look I give this
n they will still go they got a marital
issue I will say brother you no that's
that's when start is are you you don't
give the basic rights of Allah and
you're coming here complaining what's
wrong my wife doesn't listen to me
brother you don't even listen to your
lord you don't even listen to Allah you
have him pray your basic five times a
day he feeds you he looks after you and
you're complaining I told my wife to
wear uh not to wear makeup I said bro
you deserve that bro look at you man the
Disobedience you do to Allah and look
how it bothers you when you tell her
don't wear a lipstick she says get lost
you know I feel like tell you get get
lost but I hold myself back I don't want
to say that but again it goes back to
brother and sisters and I want to end on
this note um it's been tiring but uh the
point is this guys W your success is in
the Quran and the Sunnah your success is
in obedience to Allah please try it try
F in everything counselor this that try
obedience to your lord see what he does
in your life inshallah may Allah bless
our only sisters and our brothers
inshallah uh till next
time if you would like to join us as the
panel please get in contact the bitter
truth show
gmail.com good night the prophet Sall
alaihi wasallam said whoever builds a
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala Allah will build for him a similar
house in jenah on that day where Allah
subhana T tells us that our books will
be given and every little atam weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masid Allah you
helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you built
it donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra
[Music]
Rewards